what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
oh my god guys I got to tell you after
going through Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's dude the Green Lantern mythos
is amazing oh my god it's insane I
understand why so many of you guys love
Green Lantern stuff now and so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna cover the
second story arc of the Green Lantern's
and this one deals with the new Lantern
ring the phantom ring and this is
actually pretty badass this is pretty
cool to be honest I'm kind of surprised
this never happened before I'm surprised
there's never been a Lantern ring like
this but before we dive into this let's
let's do a little bit of catching up for
everybody who's new to comments
explained I'm so excited to do this
story I'm so excited to do this so with
regards to the Green Lantern's
themselves Jessica Cruz and Simon bass
they're designed to be the entry-level
Green Lantern's to the Green Lantern
mythos in DC Comics and I was figuring
this out really learning this as I was
running over the events of Hal Jordan
and the Green Lantern's the Hal Jordan
the Green Lantern is designed to
basically provide stories for the
ongoing readers the ones who have been
part of Geoff Johns mythos or read the
entirety of Geoff Johns Green Lantern
run from beginning up until the current
moment Green Lantern's is designed to
allow new people to just segue into the
mythos and quite literally learn about
the entire landscape of Green Lantern's
as Jessica Cruz and Simon Baz are
learning about it and so what we do with
this is we initially pick up with the
aftermath of the first story arc now in
that first story arc that largely dealt
with the idea of the red lanterns
returning the idea of Atrocitus trying
to conquer earth and more or less
finding everybody on earth to his will
by way of a of a hell tower more or less
by way of a giant tower that basically
allowed their anger in the rage to take
over and would eventually make them
slaves to the Red Lantern Corps of
course as we know with that story which
you'll find down in the description a
Atrocitus and his forces were defeated
and the result was that it allowed for
Jessica Cruz and Simon Baz to go about
their business as normal lanterns but in
the middle of this story
we were we were suddenly met with the
arrival of an enigmatic guardian of the
universe now to provide a little bit of
context here for those of you guys who
were new to the mythos the guardians of
the universe are really the center point
of the entire Green Lantern mythos
granted at this point right now
they've all pretty much been destroyed
with the exception of Sade and gantlet I
think all the other ones are dead and
that of course comes out of the events
on Hal Jordan the Green Lantern's and
the events leading up to it which you'll
find in the video for Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern's down in the description
but the fact remains here that the
arrival of this enigmatic guardian of
the universe was a guy we'd never heard
of before never have never before had he
ever been seen or mentioned in the
entirety of the Green Lantern mythos so
this is a brand new creation might say
alum freeze and this is really why his
run of Green Lantern's worked so well
because it's giving us new things we're
learning new things on both sides of the
equation you know Hal Jordan and the
Green Lantern's are wrapping up
basically the run of Geoff Johns as kind
of providing the last tidbits of story
are telling his Robert VIN did he's
doing it and then Green Lantern seems to
be continuing on from there giving us an
idea of what to expect and how how
Jordan will basically fold into all this
but the fact remains here that with
regards to this Guardian taking off he
had made reference to something called
the phantom ring and while he did arrive
on earth looking for Hal Jordan because
Hal Jordan was often spaced trying to
figure out what was going on with the
Green Lantern Corps and why they were
missing ultimately the the Guardian ran
into Jessica Cruz and Simon bats and
again kept sputtering off about this
phantom ring but then bailed out before
they really had a chance to ask any
questions and so what this does is this
picks up with that and it's basically
the hunt for Jessica Cruz or the hunt by
Jessica Cruz and Simon Baz to find this
to find this this weird or this this
strange guardian of the universe but
what we also learned is they're not the
only ones hunting form there are also
various alien races that seemed to be
that seem to arrived on earth for the
purpose of trying to find this Guardian
as well now of course because of the
fact that the Green Lantern's are in and
of themselves part and parcel to the
guardians of the universe
these aliens that are hunting for this
rogue Guardian basically just follow
Jessica Cruz and Simon Baz because they
know that Cruz and bads are looking for
the Guardian and so the smarter move is
to not make their presence known the
smarter move is to follow
Jessica Cruz and Simon Baz and then
ambush them potentially destroy them and
then you know take over I guess grab
this Guardium and so what we do is we
you know as Jessica Cruz and Simon
badger going about you know
trick-or-treating with their families
this is designed to be a masquerade
again to allow them to continue their
hunt by asking various people have you
seen a guy wearing this Halloween
costume so on and so forth but
ultimately Simon Simon Baz comes to the
realization that in order for this
person to be able to operate doing
whatever is they do while also being
aware of their surroundings they need to
travel to a location that has high
ground and what this does is it leads
him to realize that this person this
guardian has likely traveled to the
watchtower enough from here we
transition it's for the watchtower
itself and we pick up with this Guardian
and we basically pick up with the origin
of the Phantom ring in the sense that
you know at some point along the line
during your I guess you know before the
destruction of OA this this Lantern I'm
sorry this Guardian had created a
Lantern ring that would allow anybody to
wield it and that seems like why it's
called the phantom ring because it seems
as though maybe it's just a I don't know
if it takes on the properties of all the
other Lantern rings or what it does but
what we do know is that it allows anyone
to wield it in the sense that you have
to have sufficient willpower you have to
be deemed worthy by a by a Green Lantern
ring you have to be deemed worthy by a
yellow Lantern ring by a by a Red
Lantern rain they all the Rings have to
choose you you can't just go out and
grab a Green Lantern ring if for example
you know someone were to subdue Hal
Jordan and they were to put on his ring
it wouldn't work
because they don't have sufficient
willpower to be able to use it it's the
same reason that we've seen so far
Jessica Cruz not being able to wield or
not being able to make constructs she
doesn't have the willpower to do it now
of course that's an ongoing part of her
character and she is being expanded it
is being expanded on but we also learned
that this Guardians name is RAM II at
least I hope I'm pronouncing that right
um it's RAM er ami and this is you know
when he when he created this phantom
ring it was considered to be something
that was shunned by the original you
know guardians of the universe they
looked upon this and they said no no you
creating a Lantern ring that anyone can
wield is is going to lay waste to the
entirety of the universe now the reason
why this was done reason why this is
such a big deal is because when the
guardians of the universe sat down and
they created the Green Lantern Corps
they created them in response to the
original iteration of the Manhunter
who went rogue and they went insane and
they ended up you know cutting a swath
through a large section of the universe
before they were finally stopped the
Guardians had come to the realization
that as machines they could be corrupted
they could be screwed up their
programming could be messed with that's
exactly what happened
the former Guardian Crona hua turned
villain had screwed up the programming
of the Manhunters resulting in them
going on a rampage and so the idea of
the Guardians was okay then let's have
races do it because if they're if
they're sentient if they are humanoid in
some form or fashion or if they just
exist and they have a mind of their own
then that means they likely have empathy
and if they have empathy then that means
that they in turn will care about things
it will want to see the survival in the
protection of life and so the idea was
let's give these rings let's create
these Lantern rings let's charge them
with the central Powder a power battery
let's give each of them their own
battery and then let's give them a ring
and have them protect their own sector
the kicker here was that you had to be
selected by the ring again which was
basically a safety measure it was in
order to ensure that a Lantern ring
wouldn't fall into the hands of a person
who would use it for their own ends
hence the reason why Sinestro was
originally banished from the Green
Lantern Corps because he had a daughter
he didn't want to see her raised on such
a chaotic planet and he instead of using
his Lantern ring in order to protect the
planet or protect a sector ultimately
use his Lantern ring to instill fear and
to rule over it as a dictator now we do
know as well from Geoff Johns run that
the Green Lantern's worth the only
lanterns that the first screw to
actually tap into the emotional spectrum
and create a Lantern ring or the red
lanterns of Atrocitus but their reins
were bent on rage and so they were a
whole different ballgame from what the
guardians of the universe originally
intended but with regards to having the
Green Lantern's as a police force the
idea was to make sure that the Rings
would only fall in the hands of people
who were able to use them effectively
and so because of the fact that Ramy had
basically made a phantom ring that
anybody could pick up it would mean that
a person could pick up this ring and
turn into a one-man army not only that
we don't really know the limits of what
this ring is capable of is it possible
that this ring could dominate all the
other rings if that's the case then that
means anybody could pick up this ring
they could become a phantom Lantern they
could Bend all the other rings to their
whim and they could literally take over
the universe and so you know it presents
all
lines of different problems and so
because of this the time came where by
Ramy was basically excommunicated and he
was banished from the guardians of the
universe now the idea here seems to be
that Ramy maybe has a perspective of the
Guardians the universal have and this is
not the first time that's happened right
like there have been instances where
lanterns have sat down and they've said
the guardians of the universe don't know
everything and the guardians of the
universe cannot be trusted implicitly
they have their own motivations they
have their own plants for example the
Third Army was created in secret by the
guardians of the universe to replace the
Green Lantern's and so it's not as
though the guardians of the universe are
these altruistic beings that exist to
make sure that everyone's happy and
everybody's safe their manipulative
their controlling their not the best
kind of people to run the universe it's
also one of the reasons why Hal Jordan
had been at odds with the guardians of
the universe for quite some time but the
bigger issue here is that the phantom
ring as it's been say that by Ramy is as
old as the Green Lantern rings or at
least it's almost as old as a Green
Lantern rings and so the implication
here is that after the Green Lantern's
were created after the technology was
made to crash Lantern rings ultimately
it fell to Remmy to basically create a
Lantern ring called the phantom brain
that would serve this purpose shortly
after the Green Lantern's were made now
what we also seemed a what also seems to
be indicated here is that after Ramy was
banished by the by the original
guardians of the universe he just went
into hiding you know he basically just
took off took his phantom ring with him
now we don't know if maybe he was just
waiting for someone to come along so
that he could give the ring to them we
don't know if he simply just decided to
keep it hidden
but whatever the ring or whatever his
purpose was whatever his motivation was
he was basically thrust out he was more
or less moved out after people began to
race for that phantom ring after they
learned of its existence and began
tracking him down
hence the reason why he came to Earth in
search of Hal Jordan because Hal Jordan
would have protected him but at the same
time Hal Jordan is also largely
considered to be the greatest of the
Green Lantern's and so most likely what
seems to have happened here is Ramy had
come out of hiding after people began
tracking him down intended to give the
Phantom ring to Hal Jordan to either
protect or to use as a phantom Lantern
and an intern you know whatever happened
would have happened now the other half
of this is what was going on with Hal
Jordan himself and that's why I'm kind
of drawing out this this little
a theory here is for those of you guys
who don't know because the fact that the
Green Lantern's have been engaged in so
many conflicts over the course of their
existence almost all civilizations in
the universe had begun to look at them
with with a little bit of a glint in
their eye in the sense that they didn't
really seem to trust the Green Lantern's
as much as they used to and so the logic
of Hal Jordan was I'll go renegade I'll
make myself the villain the Green
Lantern's can capture me and then that
will restore the reputation of the Green
Lantern's that was a plan of Hal Jordan
the problem with this was that the Green
Lantern's vanished before this could
happen that was the entire basis behind
the Lost Army edge of oblivion line of
stories with regards to the Green
Lantern mythos what likely happened here
is word had reached the ears of Ramy
that Hal Jordan had effectively lost his
connection to the Green Lantern Corps
and because of this he likely decided to
give the the phantom ring to Hal Jordan
in were to allow him to wield it to be a
lantern once more I wouldn't say that's
absolutely sure and there's no
indication here that that's the case but
the fact remains that the the story
officially comes to an end the story
basically wraps up with the idea that
we're going to be seeing a phantom
Lantern we're going to be seeing a
lantern wielding this phantom ring and
the implication seems to be that someone
wants this ring that someone has learned
about it that someone has discovered
this and someone wants to be a Green
Lantern at the same time the idea also
seems to be based or be rooted in the
fact that it's a guy it's the same guy
that we had previously seen who was
originally offered a Green Lantern ring
whether the Green Lantern ring suddenly
determined that he didn't have enough
willpower and abandoned him and went and
chose Jessica Cruz instead and so the
idea is at the very least we're going to
be seeing a whole new Lantern and the
Green Lantern mythos which I don't know
about you guys but I'm very excited to
see I'm very askew I'm very curious to
see what direction this goes in but with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end if you guys are new
here to comics explain make sure you
guys hit the subscribe button become
part of the robb core and if you guys
enjoy this video drop a like because I'm
uncertainly digging what's happening
right now and let me know down in the
comments section because I'm kind of
curious let me know down in the comments
section if you could pick any one from
the entirety of the Lantern mythos
whether it's st. Walker I'm not sure if
he's alive or dead I think he's dead but
whether it's Saint Walker whether it's
Atrocitus Jessica Cruz Simon Baz Hal
George
Guy Gardner Sinestro whoever it is that
you can think of from the Lantern mythos
or even superheroes from DC in general
if you could pick one of them to wield
the Phantom ring which one would you
pick and I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]